the deaths of almost 300 people off the
Italian island of Lampedusa last October
has done little to discourage the poor
and desperate from trying to reach
European Shores some 500 men women and
children were on the boat when it caught
fire and sank poverty and conflicts like
the one in Syria mean that more
tragedies await those willing to risk
their lives for a better future one
common root for would-be immigrants is
through Greece via turkey some asylum
seekers head for the island of lesbos
about 10 kilometers off the Turkish
coast anywhere between fifteen hundred
and three and a half thousand dollars
we'll pay for a place in a crowded boat
that should be able to cross this Strait
in an hour only the higher end price
comes with a lifejacket
people smugglers can make as much as
sixty thousand dollars in one trip for
the cost of a seven hundred dollar boat
this fast boat with two powerful motors
was caught with 27 people on board they
put the lives of the migrants in danger
by using boats like this overcrowded and
especially the rubber boats more of the
reparations we have now our rescue
patients because they are advice the
migrants when the boat is approaching to
them to destroy the boat to throw the
engine into the sea and then they say
the herring Coast Guard will come in to
rescue from the sea the Coast Guard is
legally obliged to pick up people in the
water some 3600 lives were saved in
Greek seas last year ships patrol this
area 7 days and nights a week if they
spot a boat in Turkish waters the
Turkish Coast Guard must take the
would-be immigrants back any court a
screen on lesbos then moved on for
processing in holding centers elsewhere
but a few metres of water can make all
the difference it's not easy to judge
particularly at night where the border
lies and who is ultimately responsible
for these people while some make it a
Greek shores success is not guaranteed
tragedies in the Mediterranean are a
common occurrence for those who make it
this is just another part of a long
journey the authorities here keep a
close eye on the airport and ferry
terminal waiting for illegal immigrants
to take their next step